okay big news after weeks really two
months of this back and forth former
special prosecutor Robert Muller is
going to testify before Congress and as
far as we know right now it's going to
be public and it's going to be televised
and it's going to be huge right now the
date is July 17th robert muller is going
to testify before two house panels the
judiciary and the intelligence committee
panels this is according to the
respective chair people of those two
committees and I hope that enough time
is actually allocated for this that
Robert Muller can be questioned in depth
and to refresh your memory in his nearly
450 page report Robert Muller said he
could not exonerate Donald Trump from
obstruction of justice if he could have
exonerated Trump on the basis of his
investigation he would have said it in
clear and uncertain terms which he did
not and in fact Robert Moeller's report
once you got past the propagandizing of
it including through the bar letter
which we'll talk about the report
actually said there was significant
evidence of obstruction meeting all
three legal requirements of obstruction
in eight of the 14 different possible
obstructive acts into which Robert
Muller looked now what we don't yet know
is whether Robert Muller ultimately
agreed to this public testimony under
threat of subpoena because we had every
indication that Robert Muller did not
want to testify and that he had been
resisting testifying he wanted his
statement from a few weeks ago to be all
that was said in addition to the report
itself
Robert Millar actually saying the report
is my testimony and clearly that was not
good enough for Democrats in the House
and Senate and rightly so then it became
clear that Robert Muller would accept
testifying if it were private behind
closed doors and not televised and
Democrats again said it should be public
and it should be televised rightly so
and now it will be time to see what does
Donald Trump do to try to obstruct or
distract from or get in the way of these
hearings and of course to distract from
the con
and of the hearings as well and there
are a few different lines that are being
pushed on this from the trumpets so far
as of right now as of when we're taping
the show today and this may have changed
by the time you listen to or watch this
segment Donald Trump has not activated
around this news in any way but from
what I've been seeing from trumpets and
the normal right-wing trump based on
claims of the Internet there's a few
different talking points that are being
repeated ad nauseam number one is simply
nothing is going to come of this period
and nothing notable is going to be said
by robert muller repeating that robert
muller already said his full
investigation is in the report there's
nothing else to be said by robert muller
the talking point that robert molars
testifying is going to help Donald Trump
win re-election in 2020 and that
Democrats are stupid for doing this the
word nothing burger is being repeated
frequently and like with everything else
we just have to wait and see I mean
that's it if we've learned anything from
the last however long we've been
following politics and corporate media
reporting on politics it's that we need
to wait and see what actually happens
they said all along the Trump is did
that the Moller report would have
nothing in it although you had some
strategic people like Rudy Giuliani
saying oh we we expect it could be bad
in order to sort of pad the landing so
to speak but the the hardcore Trumpets
who were not working directly for Trump
were saying the Moller report is going
to have nothing and in the end the
Moller report ended up saying he can't
exonerate from there's substantial
evidence of eight counts of criminal
obstruction huge and Muller testifying
publicly on live television is also
going to be huge if you thought that
Michael Cohen's testimony was a big
event for the world of c-span and the
like Robert Moeller's testimony is going
to be orders of magnitude bigger than
that and we do not know what is going to
be said what we do know is that before
the Muller report came out
the Trump campaign the Trump
administration the Trump inner circle
ran this massive disinformation campaign
which included at it's sort of center as
its centerpiece the bar letter itself
which was a
complete and total misrepresentation of
the content of the Moller report they're
going to do it again okay no matter what
Trumpets will say molar is not a
credible person and they will attack
molar personally they will say after the
testimony molar either brought nothing
serious to the table or if he claimed to
bring something serious to the table
Muller was lying and that's why the
character assassination in advance will
be key to this strategy laying the
groundwork and we know this in advance
so we have to remember not to be
influenced in any way by what these
trumpets actors say they will attack
molars credibility no matter what they
will go after the process of the
investigation no matter what they will
continue to demand counter
investigations either into the
investigators or into Hillary Clinton or
some into Barack Obama they want
investigated so we should be setting
realistic expectations and I'll talk
about that in a second but we should not
be paying even one iota of attention to
the predictable talking points that
we're going to see from the Trump is
right so as far as the expectations go
it's not likely that Robert Muller is
going to reveal anything substantively
shocking related to the results of the
report that's not in the report but that
doesn't matter because the entire point
here is most Americans have not read the
report when I have advocated for an
immediate start to an impeachment
inquiry in the House of Representatives
it's not because I believe it will get
Trump removed from the White House from
the Oval Office
more at all or certainly not more
quickly than just voting him out in
November of 2020 the issue is that many
Americans perception of the report is
what's in the bar letter the no
collusion no obstruction talking point
circulated by Donald Trump's national
exoneration to Iran which he went after
the bar letter was published and by
having of one day hopefully multiple
days of hearings with Robert Muller will
confirm and restate what's in the report
which will be news to most Americans
that in itself will be a huge win
because it will inform people of the
content of the report something most
Americans do not know about some because
of deliberate ignorance
some because they're just busy living
their lives and so this is why in the
same way that an impeachment inquiry
would be extraordinarily useful merely
by publicizing the content of the Moller
report Moeller testifying will hopefully
do the exact same thing so that's the
news as we know it as of right now by
tonight this may even be different but
we will have more coverage of this as we
get closer to July 17th good news
overall one of today's sponsors is
impeach the cards slap game you can't
slap Donald Trump in real life but you
can slap them in this really funny and
intelligent two-player card game and you
can get it for 10% off when you go to
david pakman.com slash impeach and use
the coupon code pakman show at checkout
all one word impeach the card slap game
is perfect for having friends over or
hanging out with family members who have
a sense of humor about trump we've been
playing it at my place it currently has
a 5 out of 5 star rating on Amazon I
really don't think you'll be able to
find a game that does a better job of
satirizing today's political climate in
such an intelligent way I've had a ton
of fun with it and I think you will too
you can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary within the game we were
talking to the creators of the game and
they said one of their goals was that
players might even learn something new
as they play I think it would make a
perfect gift for anyone really of any
political orientation just because of
how clever it is or you can get it for
yourself and have a really fun and witty
game to play when people come over get
impeach the card slap game by going to
david pakman.com slash impeach and get
10% off when you use the coupon code
pakman show at checkout that's all one
word Pakman show